Ein us forschungsteam hat hinweise darauf gefunden dass es einmal eine zeit gegeben haben könnte in der der mond bewohnbar war die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler vermuten sogar dass das leben für etwa vier milliarden jahren von der erde auf den mond gelangt sein könnte
wie genau kommt das forschungsteam auf dieses wirklich spektakuläre ergebnis und was bedeutet das für zukünftige mondmissionen
die antworten jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Der mond gilt als äusserst lebensfeindlicher gesteinsbrocken denn er hat kein flüssiges wasser
keine atmosphäre und weiß extreme temperaturen auf leben wie wir es kennen galt deswegen auf dem mond lange für komplett ausgeschlossen
ein forschungsteam aus den usa ist sicher jetzt aber sicher vor langer zeit muss unser mond mal
ideale bedingungen für leben geboten haben demnach gibt es sogar zwei verschiedene zeiträume in denen der mond theoretisch
bewohnt gewesen sein könnte und zwar einmal vor 4,5 milliarden jahren also kurz nach
seiner entstehung und dann noch einmal rund eine milliarde jahre später nämlich vor etwa
3,5 milliarden jahren nach angaben des beteiligten forscher wird schulze makuch zitat ein
beachtliches zeitfenster in dem nicht nur flüssiges wasser auf der oberfläche des mondes
existiert haben könnte sondern auch
leben natürlich mikroben oder bakterien und keine grünen männchen so der mitautor der studie weiter das fazit des forschungsteams
ist also ganz klar
der mond sei lange nicht so trocken wie man immer dachte in seiner frühzeit habe er wahrscheinlich sogar sehr viel wasser aufgewiesen
möglicherweise sogar genug um einen ozean zu wild einigen dienste entsprechend
tatsächlich dafür dass der mond sogar heute noch eher feuchtes forschungsteams vermuten dass beispielsweise krater an den mondpolen
an die nie sonnenlicht gelangt bis zu einige hundert millionen tonnen eis enthalten könnten eventuell ist das nur ein kleiner rest von einer gigantischen
wassermenge auf dem mond die über viele milliarden jahre ins all verdampft ist 2009
hatte ja schon drei jahren 1 eine indische sonne die signatur wasserhaltige mineralien auf der mondoberfläche
aufgespürt doch woher stammt dieses wasser dazu gibt es mehrere mögliche antworten dazu dirk schulze makuch
wir gehen davon aus dass der mond als resultat einer gigantischen kollision der erde mit einem anderen himmelskörper vor 4,5 milliarden jahren
entstand flüchtige stoffe könnten den mond dann erhalten geblieben sein vielleicht haben aber auch asteroiden wasser
mit auf dem mond gebracht oder aber es gäste aus geschmolzenem gestein
heraus das forschungsteam verweist zudem auf dem vulkanismus der auf dem mond weit verbreitet ist und wohl vor 3,5 milliarden jahren
für die entstehung der so genannten schwarzen mond mehrere verantwortlich war auch so könnte wasser auf die mondoberfläche
gelangt sein die hätte zudem auch eine
atmosphäre auf dem mond geschaffen die man sich dreimal so dicht vorstellen könnte wie dieses maß diese hat sich wohl aber sicher
nicht besonders lange gehalten so eine studie eines anderen forschungsteams aus dem vergangenen jahr demnach sei solch eine gashülle in weniger als
100 millionen jahren
verschwunden ein ausschlusskriterium für ein mögliches leben auf dem mond ist das
dennoch nicht so dass us forschungsteam in der aktuellen studie dafür müsste die chemische evolution zwar innerhalb weniger millionen jahre aus
anorganischen baustein erste zellen geschaffen haben aber die seien nicht undenkbar
doch die damaligen lebensformen könnten auch anders auf dem mond gelangt sein und zwar von der erde aus ein
äußerst spannendes szenario denn vor etwa vier milliarden jahre wurde die erde von zahlreichen asteroiden ja bombardiert so könnten
mikroben richtung mond geschleudert worden sein falls sie den einschlag und die reise zum mond überlebt haben hätten sie dann dort weiter
existieren können so das forschungsteam die fachwelt jedenfalls
diskutiert über die neue studie hält es aber nicht für komplett ausgeschlossen dass es einmal flüssiges wasser auf dem mond gegeben hat doch selbst
wenn dies der fall war heißt das nicht dass sich in einer solchen zeitspanne auch leben entwickelt haben könnte zudem
machen eine atmosphäre und wasser noch keinen
lebensfreundlichen planeten aus das sagt das forschungsteam auch selbst auch wenn der mond vor langer zeit mal
äußerst wasserreich gewesen sein sollte sprechen geologische betrachtung eher für einen feuchten dunst der
kurzzeitig um die felsige einöde zu finden war was wir dagegen sicher wissen derzeit sind die bedingungen auf dem mond äußerst
lebensfeindlich dennoch besteht die möglichkeit dass auch heute noch flüssiges wasser existiert sicher nachweisen
ließe sich das aber nur durch eine lande sondern für die raumfahrt jedenfalls wäre solch eine entdeckung sicherlich eine
sensation denn aus dem wasser könnte man sowohl sauerstoff als auch wasserstoff gewinnen und letzterer ließe sich als antriebsstoff für raketen nutzen
wenn er kein video
dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp darum geht ihr die ein wenig
unzuverlässige abo boxee auf youtube und ihr verpasst kann wie du denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen
täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meine schwester cara klicks und social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
blogger vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken wasser auf dem mond da gibt es noch mehr infos zum thema also bis
dann
bleibt dran